so it starts with triple a then double a
then it works its way all the way down
to C and some times D these are the
credit ratings assigned to big
businesses banks countries and municipal
bonds to determine their ability to pay
back debt why are these ratings so
important because they tell you how
risky and investment is but when the
rating agencies get it wrong it can
contribute to this we are in the midst
of a serious financial crisis almost
everything they're completely wiped out
back in the 2000s ratings agencies like
Moody's and S&P gave top grades to bonds
backed by mortgages many Americans
couldn't afford that helped trigger the
financial crisis of 2008 now they're
soft-pedaling risk in the soaring M&A
market so let's explain how ratings work
using beer Bud Light is owned by the
Belgian company anheuser-busch InBev or
a bi in January a bi bar forty six
billion dollars to buy another alcohol
company which owns Coors Light sab
Miller enter the ratings agencies are
asked to evaluate and judge a bi on
dozens of attributes like indebtedness
profitability brand strength track
record and financial policy those
numbers are tallied and based on some
formulas and a lot of discretion a
letter grade is given for Moody's triple
A's at the top with investment grade
bonds going down to be a a three then B
down to C which are speculative grade or
junk these guidelines are at secret that
can be found on the company's websites
except Bloomberg ran Moody's own formula
for the a bi merger based only on its
financial metrics and discovered the
brewer carried more than double the debt
than companies with a three scores
typically support and it doesn't stop at
beer
bloomberg looked at the top five debt
funded deals from January 2015
through June 2016 all five companies
were given a higher rating than Moody's
financial metrics said they should have
Moody's says the ratings process is
subjective and certain considerations
dictate the ultimate ratings they assign
companies were often given the benefit
of the doubt as long as they had a plan
to reduce debt only time will tell what
the ratings on all of these deals will
mean for investors and the wider economy